Jumanji the next level is almost here
and we've got a fresh batch of character
posters to get you psyched along with
one for a mysterious new character and
another for a horse
you guys can G the gang or rather the
avatars are all here Kevin Hart's
Franklin Mouse Finbar Karen Gillan's
Rudy Roundhouse jack black's professor
Sheldon Shelley Oberon next Jonas's
Jefferson C play McDonough and the
absolutely brilliantly names doctor
smolder brave stone played of course by
Dwayne Johnson as for the new addition
we don't yet know her name or whether
she's a player avatar or an NPC but
she'll be portrayed by the suddenly
ubiquitous Aquafina oh and did we
mention a horse you asked yes yes we did
and if you've seen the final trailer for
the flick then you know that there's a
darn good reason for the steed to have
its own character poster first we
thought you might need some help
where is Bethany right here she says it
oh my god like I'm a total horse just in
case you're uninitiated or need a brief
refresher in 27 teams Jumanji welcome to
the jungle a group of five teens find
themselves sucked into a jungle themed
video game that must be completed before
you can escape it
Alex wolf Spencer finds himself
controlling brave stone Madison Iseman
Bethany is stuck with professor Oberon
Siderius Plains Anthony Fritz Johnson
gets Mouse Finbar and Morgan Turner's
Martha Luck's out with Ruby roundhouse
the game's most kick-ass character
together they discovered that a boy
named Alex portrayed by Mason Guccione
as a teen and colin hanks as an adult
has been trapped in the game for over 20
years
piloting the avatar of cplay McDonough
they must help him to retrieve an
in-game artifact known as the Jaguars I
defeat villainous NPC Russell Van Pelt
played by Bobby Cannavale II and
finished the game before the jungle
finishes them this time around the
entire young cast is returning but
there's an interesting new wrinkle when
Spencer repairs the game which the team
smashed at the end of the first film and
inadvertently we intercept his friends
come to the rescue but unfortunately
only Martha and Fritsch make it a martha
is the only player controlling the same
avatar as last time rich winds up with a
poorly ineffective professor Oberon
and Spencers grandfather Eddie played by
Danny DeVito and his friends Milo
portrayed by Danny Glover are
accidentally brought along for the ride
controlling brave stone and Finbar
respectively you're Spencer's
grandfather we have Florida and you Milo
walk look did I die and turn into some
kind of a small muscular Boy Scout
the trailers reveal that this gives
hearten johnson room to really flex
their comedic chops in channeling clever
and DeVito's personas and that there
will be an intriguing change of setting
or to at some point from the jungle to
the deserts the post is also indicate
that I heroes may have to contend with
some bitter cold locale along the way
case in point this poster featuring
Professor Oberon who looks absolutely
psyched to be someplace that could in no
way be described as sunny sandy or hot a
little bit chilly sure but slight
nonetheless weaknesses a character he is
mouth looking about as confounded as she
would be if you were a septuagenarian
grandpa who suddenly found yourself
transported into the world of one of
those newfangled video games we only
briefly hear hearts impersonation of
Glover and the trailers but boy is it
ever spot-on
next up Gillen it's Ruby rounds house
looking as badass as ever
we can't help but point out that it will
never stop blowing our minds that this
is a same actress who portrays nebula in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and it
only takes about three to five hours in
the makeup chair to render her
completely unrecognizable and somehow
even more badass
he has Jonah sassy play McDonough this
time around it'll be Spencer controlling
the avatar
although Hanks will return to adult
version of Alex who had the dubious
honor of being stuck a seaplane for a
couple of decades ah yes and here's the
horse although it is not just a horse
it's actually an avatar and spoiler
alerts for at least part of the movie is
controlled by Bethany then there's
awkwafina's new character who is seen
only briefly in the trailer making it
tough to pass out our motivations she
appears to be an NPC and it's even
possible that she's the game's new
villain particularly since it seems like
Connor volleys vamp elves won't be
returning for this flick she's
certainly looks a bit sinister although
that could simply be misdirection
finally there's a smouldering doctor
brave stone remember it's an elderly
grandpa played by Danny DeVito at the
avatars controls this time and the
trailer suggests that if you ever had
any doubts as to how up personally funny
the rock can be you'll soon be putting
them to rest
Jumanji the next level is directed by
Jake Aston who also helmed welcome to
the jungle he co-wrote the screenplay
with returning scribes Jeff Pinkner and
Scott Rosenberg the flick hits the big
screen on December 13th check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bowel so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]